I used this very same method to rank
this article number one on Google and
outrank my competitors. And in today's
video, I'll be showing you how you can
do this yourself. So, first thing that
you want to do is enter in this Claude
skill into Claude. If you want to get
this skill, just comment SERP s e r p in
the comments below and I'll send it over
to you. So, how this works is you first
enter in a query of the topic or the
keyword in which you would like to rank
for. For this example, I wanted to rank
for the keyword self-employed mortgage
in Ontario. And what this Claude skill
does, it first goes out and it does full
SERP analysis of that specific keyword.
So, I've went ahead and put in that I
want to rank for the keyword
self-employed mortgage in Ontario. And
then went out and it did a SERP pull.
So, it used some tools. It's going to
use either Claude in Chrome if you have
it connected. If not, it will use the
Claude
web search mode. So, we see here it went
out and it searched up the top-ranked
articles for that specific keyword. So,
mortgage options from RateShop,
nesto.ca,
Cameron mortgage ratehub.ca, RBC Bank,
rate rates.ca, wowwa.ca, so on and so
forth. If I go back over to the SERP
overview,
I could see RateHub, Royal Bank, Nesto.
These are all the same
um the same um article or sorry, the
same websites that are ranking in the
SERP. So, went ahead and found the same
websites, right? So, it found some
search results. It then analyzed the top
five URLs.
So, it got the top results. Now,
fetching and reading each of the top
five articles for deep analysis. So, it
went through each article, read through
the full article, analyzed it, read
through the second article, so on and so
forth until the fifth article. So, once
all five articles were analyzed, it then
was able to pull my site map, my brand
voice from Word Rocket so that it knows
exactly how to write within my specific
niche. Now, the thing that's really
important about this method
is that it not only just pulls the
information, it does a complete SERP
analysis, builds a brief, as you can see
here, and then it sends that complete
brief over to Word Rocket. So, we can
see here, it's went ahead and done the
analysis of the top five articles. We
have the title to beat/model. So, these
are the meta title and meta descriptions
that we need to beat. Shared keywords in
top five. And then we have a full brief
here. Right? So, it tells us what we
need to do. It tells us exactly what um
our competitors have done any content
gap analysis of what we need to write
about if we want to outrank our
competitors. And once the analysis is
completed, it then fires the article
over to Word Rocket with the full SERP
informed brief.
Right? So, as we can see here, it's
generated the article. It's waited a few
minutes until the images were completed,
and then it's going to post this article
directly over to my WordPress site. So,
again, if you want to get access to this
um to this SOP, just comment SERP in the
comments below, and I'll send it over to
you guys. So, I just want to head over
to Word Rocket, and we want to actually
see if this article
has been generated. And here we see the
article, self-employed mortgage in
Ontario has been generated. So, I'm
going to just I'm going to just click
into this article. Right? So, we see
here, self-employed mortgage in Ontario
2026 complete guide and qualifying rates
and lenders. Beautiful image here. We
get geo-optimization.
We got our key takeaways.
Right? We got our table of contents, and
our images are still generating, so give
it a couple of seconds here. But, we see
that the full article has been generated
not based upon what we think, but based
upon the information that Claude was
able to pull from a SERP analysis. We
also get a custom interactive
self-employed mortgage qualifier, which
looks really, really good. So, we can
actually go ahead and see what that
looks like. So, again, full article that
we're able to get back here. Our GEO
score was pretty high, 75 out of 100.
So, if you wanted to view what this
looks like, this HTML, we can pop it
into an HTML viewer, and as you can see
here, it's an Ontario self-employed
mortgage qualifier. So, you enter in
your income,
and then your second year income,
your down payment,
and then you can calculate your
qualifying amount. So, you can see
what you would qualify for based upon
your net income from year one and year
two. So, pretty cool, huh? Like, this
actually is very very neat. I like it,
and you can change it based upon your
specific market. So, I really like this,
and this is all one-shot generated
in our Claude SEO skill using Word
Rocket. So, as you can see, using this
method, you're able to do an adapt
custom SERP analysis based upon a
specific keyword that's real life and up
to date. You can use that information to
send it over to Word Rocket to write
your article in a way that is
customizable for your brand, SEO
optimized, has custom images, web mode,
GEO optimization included as well, with
internal links, all in one place. You
combine powerful research with a
powerful writing tool, and you get a
powerful article that will rank on
Google. Hope that you guys enjoyed
today's video. If you did, let it be
known by giving us a big thumbs up, and
I'll see you in the next one. Take care.